Asik oh right - boom welcome back to
some more outlast it was a broken like a
10 million ribs I don't think you have
that many button what are you do I know
come on get up brah go Brad we got this
breath any day son have a Pepsi
sir problems gross oh yeah there was a
female Ward that we never saw I remember
that I remember was like what there's
because there's a little only boys now
at last that we've seen at least maybe
put this away now so I guess it would
make sense they put it in the DLC I
don't know we'll have to see get it I
saw something
maybe I'm going insane what oh my god no
I don't
okay I like goat here my goat here oh
thank you
where are they why do I have to be such
a goat i'ma go hello
okay I think that was a real goat
actually you might want to get the real
not actually real oh god why am I
wasting okay so we got some why are you
so scared
I love fabulous oh we are [__] so very
fun are you a goat
I can't board already I'm sorry skip
where do you go what the [__]
Jesus this game really like making me
immune to jump scares how am I going
that's different okay I don't know how
to okay no I don't want a dime ago
don't I so easy [__] should be enough
this is very poorly built whoever is the
construction officers clearly was
sleeping most of the time it's okay I
like napping - this is nice this would
be great if this would open how do I end
up in these shitty situations all the
time that's what she said [__] are they
talking about passive JT though it's my
favorite dad days
god I love possum titties I wish I had a
pair of two possum titties right there
man that would be so no no no no I'm
really oh no this is very bad
god dammit wow this closes after me I'm
the groom what the [__] inside I don't
want to know
actually that's okay
go
[Music]
what you gonna do about that what's it
gonna do a bad thing what you gonna do
about that oh it's me thought I was
gonna get married
glad you have it whoa my shut up scared
me haha okay huh it's like a sewing
factory I love I love sewing it's my
favorite best activity all right Oh
[Music]
oh oh oh oh oh no no batteries on the
monix gun he can't go on I am speechless
what in the [__] I see my Bioshock now
[__] I'm doing
I actually honestly have no [__] clue
but I'm not wearing any shoes and that's
all that matters girl that's all that
matters
don't know where any shoes don't worry
any shoes god I'm running out of
batteries [__] oh job not it sock hey
Jesus what am I supposed to go come on
okay there's someone out there yeah
there is how did he find me
oh it's him I'm right here baby
we'll run away and get married one day I
promise it's a love story
Robbie take me somewhere we can be alone
I love you and that's all I really know
talk to your dad him picking out a white
dress it's a love story baby just say
yes just say yes Juliet bury me you'll
never have to feel I'm a table I'm the
best table in town
oh boy I'm a nice table I tabled all my
days even the bad days I table even the
right day side table maybe the wrong
days I know if they gonna sneak out as a
table as a good table once said and as a
good cable once will do table are
awesome like a possum titty
haha daily high-five my face because I
missing okay
right there no all right let's go to his
little office in
[Music]
oh we are home let me close that you
never know crazy people out there you
never know
Oh wonderful
I don't know time for finger painting
I'm gonna have to keep going
saving don't like that that's like it
that's that guy warning for you shits
about to go down in your pants bra
I am cereal I don't know why you
wouldn't think oh that's my dress he
picked me out the white dress it's a
love story baby what no no no no no no
he's sick at second
Oh God
[__] are those space alien things
I keep sailing away said an open cause
for the Virgin you see and I got to be
through alive
she heard me I think I escaped that
[__] pretty well know the shape all
right
what new push push push baby sexes take
the trumpet and you put that bottom note
you will get married one day one day I
promise no [__]
all right fall and die or get married
fall and die
Oh get married I'll get married no holy
night all right there we go
family oh [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
Oh who the [__] works at security Oh
Braille no I'm come back to me said hi
[Music]
no no it's not true
oh no she was cereal I would never mind
I have milk [__] I got so much
I'm open smack I gotta get a skin it's
totally cray-cray
there is no place I come I agree woman
you were very wise very wise indeed all
right it's gonna follow this what is
that saying
ain't nobody my mama ain't happy ain't
nobody happy ain't nobody happy no mom
my girl that's true
this guy's very white oh [__] my oh gosh
oh gosh Oh guys
oh hell okay they wanted you to go in
here darling
now delicacy to be unwrapped do I get to
wear a dress yes / no / maybe did he
lock me in what did I lock myself in I'm
vulgar and I want to say I'm sorry
I just you know how a man gets it's okay
I'm beautiful okay make sense
a legacy should be the father I know
I'll never
like like Hoover
can I can I go out now please
[Music]
Oh loving it here Oh God not Bieber's
perfume Oh God not anything uh sorry but
it's time to end this episode every
episode has come to an end unfortunately
but I'll be enjoy waiting
leave a like right now if you did and
I'll see you tomorrow love you best
[Music]